[Music]
for the last hundred years the royal
academy of dance has been preparing
students to teach
the stars of the future and thanks to
the government's culture recovery fund
it will at least for now be saved
what would happen without it well the
arts would be in a a desperate state
and that i know how difficult and
challenging it is for people who are
working
in this industry at the moment darcy
bussell says this money is a lifeline
but knows just how acute the crisis in
the arts has become
not to be overdramatic but it is like a
death do you think
uh for so many of these students
uh going into this art form that they've
been passionate about this is not just a
job this is their life
it has been devastating to think that
they can't get on with their jobs
they can't keep inspiring they you know
you don't get paid much to be in this
industry anyway so they do it for the
love of it
this fund is largely about protecting
institutions like this one
rather than individuals yet the bedrock
of the arts are its freelancers
many of whom fear for the future
the old vic in bristol received the six
hundred thousand pounds it needs to
survive
but bosses insist the sector needs more
the rationale for the government is you
fund the
venues and the institutions and actually
they employ the workforce
but the workforce equally need funding
because what will happen is we can't
employ
everyone all in one go it takes time
um and so there is a risk that people
skilled people will fall out of the
industry
gareth turner was a freelance tour
manager working all over the world
now back in bristol i'm supposed to have
a tour
in april next year but
i just don't see it happening so what
are you doing instead you are
i am just maintenance yeah which is fine
i mean i love it here it's great
great crew here but you've had to
completely change your life
because the industry it's gone
and with so much of live music theater
performance
still on hold the arts will need more
than this recovery fund
to fire on all cylinders again lucy
cotter
sky news